et pareil cas une grosse surprise pour
moi john mamann sûr j'en parle des prix
mais c'est un peu toute l'équipe qui je
compose mon album qui arrive et puis
stromae s'est rajoutée à l'équipe et ça
a été merveilleux et on a créé peine et
peach et que le single en évoquant ce
moment clé où on va on va regarder je
suis super contente
ouais et voilà m et john ont fait tout
l'album ensemble et c'est vraiment c'est
mon frérot donc je fais des bisous et
stromae aussi on l'ombre à surface il a
l'occasion de nous regarder
ou alors comme à hésiter qu'il avait les
fans de l'émission il est fan des
marseillais l'avouer en studio à des
moines démarquer vraiment il va se
marier et la définition il regarde à une
disette qui regardait que sa femme
ministre y sont fans et tous et il adore
tpm pays regardez je crois qu'il regarde
d'ailleurs je pense qu'ils regardent ce
qui m'a écrit tout à l'heure
[Applaudissements]
dans le public on peut la balance est
d'inciter madame on voit qu'il ya une
vidéo
total essayé nous offre une white a fait
un petit truc spécial c'est vrai pour
nous pour travailler et il fait jamais
de vidéos
non mais je sais non mais vie qui m'a
dit je veux lui faire une vidéo j'aime
beaucoup de séries j'ai voulu faire un
pli saint amour on espère toucher
franchement je travaille donc nous
gagnons dans une vidéo le web alors en
régime à stromae basse et c'est le vrai
tout ça c'est pas une vanne pas vrai je
vais avoir un engagement citoyen parce
que je les connais c'est ça fait deux
ans qu'il n'a pas parlé ce trauma il
nous appelait évident qu'on a c'est
vraiment c'est pour toi et pour toute
l'équipe ce qu'elle aime tout le monde
et non non c'est bon vous cadeau non
j'ai pas mes trousses
bonjour tpp bonjour baba bonjour les
chroniqueurs bonjour vita je ne peux pas
être là malheureusement mais je voulais
quand même faire un gros gros bisous et
je suis super fier du morceau [ __ ] pitié
d'ailleurs il y en a un autre qui
arrivera qu'on a composé avec john
mamann aussi donc voilà je suis super
fier de ce qu'on a accompli est super
fiers de vous faire un coucou est passé
dans l'émission ce que je la regarde
souvent j'ai envie de faire un gros
bisou aussi à notre chère isabelle
morini-bosc c'est ma préférée de tous
les chroniqueurs l'avocat
donc si les chiens grève avant les
séries ce travail
roma et sait où ça fait deux ans qu'il
va mal à passer mais vous savez que je
suis mais comme un ouf sur stromae même
aux îles c'est le plus gros mais je
l'adorent et les chéris il ya un truc de
ouf je vous le dis c'est que stromae m'a
appelé pendant la vidéo on va le
rappeler je devais vraiment c'est
vraiment le stromae qui m'a appelé on
dirait que maintenant on verra mais
jamais je suis fou de soutien il a fait
deux ans qu'il n'a pas parlé injustices
il n' ya plus comestible merci voilà
merci ben il va peut-être pour rappelé
trop mal ici ou francesca émersion
lembras sports hall m et c'est un génie
on a hâte de la voir un jour de tnt
c'est un garçon pour l'appareil merci
pour la survie énormissime parce que
sélectionne un voilà je suis fan de lui
en a des milliers de femmes de ce
travail mais on fait tous partie oui à
mener c'est trop bas et je vous jure
c'est vrai c'est vraiment se trouvait à
l'eau
mais bon
au marais
[Applaudissements]
comment ça et je promets tu sais que
j'ai jamais eu l'occasion de te parler
c'est que je suis fou de toi
sans déconner tu peut m'amener n'importe
qui mois brad pitt je m'en fous lorsque
nous mais je m'en fous ouais je te le
dis je signe bébert tout ça c'est toi le
plus bas en trois mois et à l'amour et
j'espère qu'un jour franchement si tu
veux un jour sur le plateau je te jure
je te fais un prime spécial
je m'étais photos partout je n'ai cessé
d'aider voilà je fais tout pour toi
parce que tu aimes fort était vraiment
t'aider doigté le patron voit la journée
te dirai je t'aime très fort et bravo
parce que tata xv italien entend
bassement est en pleine forme vraiment
attendu s'étaient pas entendus bien sûr
mais si tu veux de l'oseille sinémurien
et fort allez on embrasse fort aussi et
ce travail et c'est la grande classe
voilà on les fout de toi reste comme tu
es tft le patron un génie on t'aime très
fort et j'ai hâte de te rencontrer un
jour je t'embrasse très fort son bail
on se croirait hier pamela anderson
aujourd'hui ce cobaye le passé l'algérie
l'état est avec nous alors
[Applaudissements]
ad oui barack obama je te rappelle on va
pas crier occupez celui-là